how's it going guys welcome back to
openal this is tutorial2 today we're
going to be talking about
streaming audio and just so uh open ale
you know if you haven't watched the
first video you should probably watch it
it's got the real intro
to this series and everything this is
going to be like just a walking through
code and showing you how to get the
streaming done so not quite as fancy as
the first one but still
very important and very cool so i'm
gonna go ahead and talk about all that
but
of course if you like this kind of
content you can uh you know hit the like
button don't forget to
do what you can to support us creators
so we can keep creating and teaching you
for free
and also if you want to uh donate i i do
have a patreon so you're welcome over
there
i went ahead and pulled the latest from
what was on the repo
and just started updating it now really
all i did
was add this one class called music
buffer which handles
everything about the music now uh in
retrospect
music buffer might not be the best name
for this because
well it does have the music buffer it
really has everything about the music
and it's sort of separate from sound
effects
because uh the sound effects are all
pulled like you can load up a bunch of
sound effects and then play them by
their id
so that's how we did the sound effects
but the music's a little different
i'm making the music so that you're just
going to instantiate
one of these classes called music buffer
anytime
you want music available so basically
when you want to play music you have to
instantiate a music buffer and give it a
file name
and there is no default constructor
because it has to have some file to play
um and that way we don't pull up we
don't
uh save a ton of music because uh you
know
music files can be big sure you could
load up a bunch
but i'm kind of thinking along the lines
of keeping it simple and in a game you
typically aren't playing
two or three music tracks at a time it's
usually just one music track
so that's what i've geared this towards
is the thought of just playing one music
track
at a time we are carry we're gonna hold
some private
variables here basically this whole
class does everything so i'll just walk
through all of that
so of course we need a source and we
need to know the sample size that we're
going to buffer
and how many buffers from what i was
reading
these seem to be good numbers to work
with as defaults but
we could add in features to change these
a little bit
and four buffers that way it cycles
through these same four buffers
like when it's done playing the first
one it marks it as
uh done playing that way it can put new
date in there and it basically just
loops through these four
buffers to play the entire song however
long it may be
so that way it doesn't need to take up
a ton of memory it just has four blocks
of this 8192
and here we have buffers that we're
going to generate
now sound file we want to keep track of
the file and the data from the file so
that's why we're keeping this variable
here
and the reason is we're going to keep
loading it into these buffers
so as we go along we'll have to keep
updating it and pulling it from the data
and that's why we keep these and then
the info of course of what the data's
like
and there's our actual pointer to the
memory of what uh
of the music of the sound and of course
we need to keep track of the format too
well we only have two real functions
that you ever call and that is play and
update
aside from the constructor
so let's go ahead and take a look at all
of that
let's look at the instantiation first
not i haven't put pause and stop in here
yet i probably won't
right now they're not too hard to
implement
anyone is welcome to work on this code
if you uh visit it on github and
and want to play around with putting
adding in these functions or making
stuff a little better you're totally
welcome to
it might be a good way for you to get
practice too
so when we instantiate a new music
buffer we need to give it a file name
and what it does is it goes
goes ahead and generates the source
which is like
the what would you call it the speaker i
was calling it the speaker last episode
i don't know if that's the best term for
it some people call it like a cd player
while the data is the cd that's sort of
similar
but it also kind of works as where the
sound
volume comes from so i was thinking
speaker but maybe it's more like a boom
box or something
but yeah it generates that and we
generate
four of the buffers so this gen buffers
takes a number and we're passing in four
from this constant value
and a pointer to those um
the array of fours so that's going to go
ahead and generate all four of those so
we can use those
so we want to keep track of or we want
to keep the frame size later for loading
and our sound file is we're just using
that library to open our file
based on the file name and we're doing a
read
and we want to also pass in this info so
it can populate the info which
that that we'll use for the channels and
some other things a little later
so rather than continuing we're going to
throw if this completely fails so if it
fails to open your file it's just going
to
throw and should give you this message
that way you can double check
that your path is correct
and then we just check what the sound or
the format
was which this should have it so in our
channels we just compare it to some
values that correlate with
al and how it wants to hold them
and we just set it to the correct one so
we want to set our
format variable to uh whatever is proper
so we're just doing some checks here
and we just check that it actually has a
format if for some reason it didn't set
a format we're going to close everything
and then just throw an error of
unsupported channel that means
your music file has something weird
going on that's not very normal
and here is our frame size which we're
going to populate with
the buffer the number of buffalo buffer
samples that's the 8192
number and it's going to be times by the
number of channels and then
we're going to set that or times that by
the size of a short so that
is our frame size
and then we go ahead and allocate all
the memory
oh yeah just a memory allocation into
our member so
that pointer will now point right to
that data
and here we have the destructor now this
just does what you would expect it just
frees memory and closes things
includes handling the openal source and
deleting that and the buffers but it
also closes our sound file
and sets it to null and freeze our
memory so that should be enough anytime
you're done with your music
to just let this go out of scope
and or handle it however you want
but in general if it goes out of scope
it's done so it should clean up after
itself
okay now let's look at the play function
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to clear any errors and with open
al you do that with git error
that's just in case i'm really just not
necessary
if everything's fine which it should be
but just in case
we're going to go ahead and do that so
we don't have any errors write off that
are confusing
usually you want to check for errors
anytime you do something
so the first thing we're going to do is
rewind our source
when we hit play and
we're going to set this buffer to zero
so that just basically clears the buffer
because we're gonna fill it here in a
second
and yeah here we fill the buffer queue
basically we end up buffering all the
data
um for all four cues
so we go off the number of buffers we
just fill all four of those buffer cues
right off
right into our buffer data
and there's all the variables we need to
do that
for that al buffer data function
and then we check for an error and if
there's an error we just throw and say
hey we couldn't buffer so there's
something critical going on
there if it doesn't work now that it's
all buffered up
we can queue and start playback and you
do this with al source
q buffers so use that function and then
you just hit play on the source so it is
a little different than playing sound
effects you have to use this al
source q buffers rather than and that's
pretty much it for that function
but something you need to do as you
continue along with your program is you
need to update the buffer stream so once
it gets through those initial four
from the starting play it's not going to
do anything
unless it has more data to go through
and to do that we need to call this
update buffer stream every once in a
while
pretty frequently really to just to
rebuffer
anything that's done played basically we
just
check the state see how many are
processed
and then we uncue
anything that's already processed
and cue up new data
to anything that
needs new data there's a little
uh ending part here that basically just
to analyze this it does say if your
state is not playing and not
paused so i guess that would be stopped
starts playing again
okay so i think this is the case of uh
you've played off the buffer already
and by the time you got to re-cueing
more data
it was no longer playing so this just
starts the playing again as it buffers
i'm pretty sure that's what it does
okay well that's all the functions in
our main here we just have a few new
things
the rest is still the same i changed
this to just a knit
that way it we don't really need the
taxes the sound device anymore we just
need to initialize it so that's fine
and we play our two sounds from last
time
but now we're also gonna instantiate a
music buffer called
my music and we're gonna pass it this
town theme
dot wave and this was from open game art
town rpg now this came as an mp3 and
open al doesn't seem to like mp3s
so i did have to open audacity here and
just go
yeah i just drug this file into it and
then i went to
file export as wave to turn it into a
wave instead
so that's now on the resources of this
repo and then we just hit
play now this will play for a very short
duration
unless we actually update the buffer
stream and just as a quick hack to get
it to go
and get it done i just put a while one
in here this also means that the program
will never exit so you have to crash the
program
but it does get the music playing so it
should play these two sound effects and
then
play this main music and continue to
update the buffer stream
until it's done i'll just fix it right
now
now i could put this update buffer
stream within the play
of this music too kind of like how it is
with the sound effects but
we're going to be moving away from that
going forward because
that's really just a little hack to
see if it's still playing or not okay so
now once this is uh
once the state is no longer playing
it should exit the program all right
let's let's give it a go
[Music]
and that'll do it so it looks like this
all works pretty well
for what it is and once again this is
just a sample instantiation
of this whole feature of being able to
play these things
feel free to edit it feel free to change
things going forward we're going to
start messing with
spatial stuff so we're going to get into
3d sounds and
it's going to get a little bit more
complicated and
a bit more code heavy so i'm going to
try to break it up into small sections
and just do a little
every once in a while but also i could
really use your support on the series
the more support it gets the more i'm
going to continue it the more i'm going
to focus on it
because i think that makes sense at this
point is to actually focus on things
that people
would like to see and uh
and that sort of thing all right well i
appreciate you guys thanks for watching
see you in the next one
[Music]
you